let's continue taking calls we will go
next at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 52 our callers from the 805 area code
caller from 805 please introduce
yourself and tell me what's on your mind
today
hey Pat I mean hi David hi Pat hey just
a two-part two little questions first
David how's your new career as a
professor going at Boston College and
and second question is how come well I
don't know if you've considered doing a
short segment or a show maybe in Spanish
have you ever thought about doing that
things that be interesting and that's
all just one say hello to you and again
like that okay so let's see my career as
a college professor is going well well
so far I would say we've had one that
the semester just started if people
don't know what we're talking about I am
teaching as adjunct faculty professor
Pakman for lack of a better term at
Boston College a premier learning
institution of the United States and
particularly here in the Boston area I
think is fair to say and it's going
pretty well so far and I I'm enjoying it
I don't you know I'm still getting up to
speed in terms of what it's like to be a
college professor and sort of learning
the ins and outs but it's going well and
I'll talk more about that maybe later in
the semester segments in Spanish yeah
people have asked about me doing
segments in Spanish if you're wondering
but why would I do a segment in Spanish
rather than any other language I was
born in Argentina my first language is
Spanish I learned English as a Second
Language
only when I immigrated to the United
States it's an interesting idea but the
thing is we are an english-language
youtube channel and thus almost everyone
who subscribed to the channel doesn't
speak Spanish sure there are some
bilingual individuals who subscribe to
our YouTube channel or maybe to the you
know listen to the show on the radio or
whatever that happened to also speak
Spanish but I don't want to create
content that sort of structurally is not
gonna be appealing to a large majority
of the audience I don't know if it makes
sense to to speak in Spanish when you're
talking about American politics so much
as
if you were talking about Spanish
politics or South American politics so
we would have to reinvent the show
altogether I think that there's an
argument to be made that there would be
value in having a Spanish language
program about American politics Fernando
espuelas who is from from the I think
he's from you do guai but lived in
Argentina for a while he's been on the
program before he does a show I believe
on Univision radio that's like half
Spanish half English and it's all about
American and world politics very very
good program tremendous program and it's
an interesting format but we didn't
start that way so I don't know that it
would make sense to start doing
something like that well they're
interesting and yeah I want to get your
thoughts on that and I thank you for
taking my call all right thanks
appreciate the call always interesting
to hear about all the topics that are on
the mind of people in the audience